marry my money lives in El Alto just
outside Bolivia's capital La Paz like
many other Latin American countries the
government has imposed a mandatory
quarantine for all citizens but my money
who works as a taxi driver is afraid
about how she's going to feed her
eight-year-old son as a mother it is
painful because you open your
refrigerator and see it empty every day
the food runs out as a mother I don't
know what I'm gonna feed my son what are
you doing as a mom I stopped eating for
example three weeks ago I bought some
chickens because I was working with my
taxi I keep the chicken for my son I
don't eat my son is the one who eats I
prefer that my son eats and not me
coronavirus is just starting to spread
in Latin America and governments are
taking harsh measures to control it
there's over 10,000 cases in the region
and those figures are likely to increase
in Argentina president Alberto Fernandez
has just extended the ongoing quarantine
until mid-april thousands have been
detained in Argentina and the military
is using helicopters to control
compliance with a quarantine security
forces are controlling the end
to the city of when aside if they're
detaining and confiscating the vehicles
of those who do not have permits to be
on
it's an enormous challenge for
authorities here but the government says
that this is the necessary measure to
prevent the spread of the virus but
there is one country whose president
remains in denial about the dangers of
kovat 19 Brazil's Jaya balsa Naru who
insists government's should prioritize
the economy the virus is there and we're
going to have to face it we're going to
have to face it like men not like
children we're going to face the virus
with the reality of life we're all going
to die some day on Sunday two of his
tweets were deleted by Twitter because
they violated the rules of use by
potentially putting people at greater
risk of transmitting the virus the posts
were videos of the tour that the
president took in the federal district
contrary to the guidelines of his own
Minister of Health who recommended that
people stay at home as a measure to
fight the corona virus in Brazil slums
NGOs are stepping up efforts to help the
poor the investment in social security
in the country is being reduced from
year to year in the last four years and
believe it in this year in the middle of
the corona virus pandemic we're having
reductions on both of Familia so that's
absolutely crazy government action is
the only way millions of people in the
region have to survive the months ahead
Teresa and Jesse de Buenos Aires well
let's talk to gustavo Ribeiro
about the situation in Brazil in how the
president there is handling this crisis
is a journalist and founder of the
Brazilian report which is an online
magazine his vice kite from South Paulo
Gustavo very good to have you with us on
al-jazeera so why is presidential Boston
ro seeking to minimize this pandemic and
is his messaging his approach is it
resonating at all with Brazilians
thanks for having me President Bush
senado is doing the political
calculation what his do is in Brazil's
political system the president can only
do so much and state governors and
mayor's have a lot of power so he's
putting the burden of stopping the
economy
on local administrations and if they
work because every single governor in
Brazil has put at least some
restrictions in place some power phrases
where I am we are the largest the the
most populated state in Brazil with
country's economic heart and for a week
now the state has been in quarantine and
we remain in quarantine for at least
seven more days so if these measures
work and the country can at least seek
some normality in short-term future he
will say you see I told you it was
nothing he has said time and again that
it's just a snare for that we have seen
worse pandemics that the onine h2 h1n1
pandemic was worse and his calculation
is if the country stops if unemployment
explodes his approval ratings which are
already low you go even further down
right so how are Brazilians feeling
about the way he's handling this then
it's his messaging resonating at all
with them I read that 1/3 1/3 of
Brazilians think he's doing an excellent
job handling this pandemic who are these
Brazilians well opinion polls show that
while the president has retained his
approval ratings most of Brazilians do
not agree with how he's handling the
kovat 19 crisis still they approve his
overall job but yes his message does
resonate with a lot of people especially
young males lower middle class yesterday
we had motorcades in several state
capitals asking for the country to
resume normal activity so the
president's words are actually having
the practical effect in a lot of regions
here yeah and you know a lot of people
of course compared him to Donald Trump
but even Donald Trump his ally has
changed his rhetoric somewhat do you
think this economy first plan that John
the Jefferson arrow is putting forward
cost him politically ultimately I think
we will certainly cost him because
companies are already laying off people
it's impossible to just go back to
normal life because the problem is not
the restrictions it's not the quarantine
is the virus and if we still have the
virus we will still have problems so a
lot of companies are already laying off
people the economy Minister just
announced today that they will suspend
the unemployment data to disclose
unemployment data for now and last week
we saw in the u.s. that we had a record
number of people fighting for
unemployment so the government wants
seems to be actively withholding this
important data that might cost Bose
another politically thank you thank you
so much for talking to us about this
Gustavo Riviera Brazilian journalist
joining us there from Sao Paulo thank
you for your time thank you